foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ridge on Sunday it's a particularly
poignant remembrance Sunday this year
the first led by King Charles after the
death of his mother with the nation
preparing to fall silent at 11 o'clock
but before that we're going to focus on
a critical week in Westminster because
in just four days time Jeremy Hunt will
deliver what is a budget in all but name
it's likely to Define his time as
Chancellor and the conservative hopes at
the next election but more importantly
it will affect all of us and an economy
that's probably already in recession now
we know there will be tax Rises when
incomes are already squeezed and
spending cuts when public services are
already struggling and that is a very
difficult message to deliver we'll look
at the task ahead with our guests this
morning
well in a moment I will be talking to
you the chancellor himself Jeremy hunts
and we'll be talking to his opposite
number for labor the shadow Chancellor
Rachel Reed on the program this morning
plus Simon Clark the former leveling up
secretary under Liz truss will give us
his first interview since leaving
government
with spending cuts on the agenda and
more strikes to come we'll talk to
Christina mcenay the General Secretary
of the Union unison
Plus on Remembrance Day the chief of the
defense staff Admiral so Tony radican
has been speaking to our defense and
security episode Deborah Haynes
foreign
[Music]
well he's just a few weeks into the job
and Thursday's Autumn statement could
already be career defining for the new
Chancellor well Jeremy Hunt has been on
the show already this morning he's
repeatedly told us that there will be
eye-wateringly difficult decisions made
on spending cuts and tax Rises with the
UK likely already in recession we spoke
to Jeremy Hunt about his plans for the
economy
before we get to the Autumn statement
how will you be reflecting this
remembrance Sunday well I'm going to be
remembering my father who died eight
years ago and was in the Navy all his
life and I'll be thinking about him but
also I think all of us will be thinking
about the brave ukrainians who have been
on the front line Fighting For Freedom
not just for them but actually for all
of us and I think it's a reminder that
we can never be complacent if we want to
defend the things we really believe in
is defense spending something that
you're going to be prioritizing next
week then it's really important I will
be talking about it there are lots of
things we need to resolve when it comes
to defense spending but if you're asking
is the prime minister am I committed to
making sure that we can defend our
country and the values we believe in
absolutely yes and now I do want to
um talk about what we can expect next
week and I want to do things a bit
differently because I know obviously
with these interviews you're very
limited in what you can say so rather
than just running through a whole load
of potential policies and you saying to
me I can't talk about them and I'm going
to try and keep things a bit more Broad
and if you could answer things as full
as you're able given obviously the the
concern that so many of our viewers are
frankly having at the minute with the
inflation costs and and potential
austerity to come as well and you've
warned of decisions of eye-watering
difficulty does this mean we are going
to be seeing a return to austerity
well they are going to be very difficult
decisions but we are a resilient country
and we've faced much bigger challenges
frankly in our history and we know that
to deal with problems you have to face
into them not run away from them and
we're also a compassionate country and
so a plan that I outlined to the House
of Commons on Thursday will be one that
gets us through these difficult times
but also shows that British compassion
the support for the most vulnerable
people and probably the single thing
that is the biggest worry to people on
low incomes actually to everyone is the
rising cost of bills Energy prices going
up and so we will outline a plan to hold
down the rises in Energy prices and
chart our way to a longer term World in
which we're not dependent on what Putin
does he can't just suddenly see our gas
prices shoot up
having that long-term plan in place is I
think the way that we can give people
confidence that we'll get through this
so will there be a new plan on energy
because you're warning aren't you in
Sunday times today about the
sustainability of the current plan and
the man that's costing us well we Face a
global energy crisis uh the increase in
our national Energy bill over the last
couple of years is about 140 billion
pounds it's like the economy supporting
an entire second NHS
and if we're going to tackle that and
deal with the worry that for example a
pensioner has about the you know massive
increase in in the gas bill the
electricity bill and so on then we need
a long-term plan for the country for
clean energy for green energy for cheap
energy that isn't affected by
international events so absolutely I'll
be setting out that plan on Thursday
um you talk about pensioners is it
likely that support could be more
targeted to people who are more
vulnerable but we want to support people
who need support we don't want anyone
not to be able to afford to heat their
home over this winter or indeed future
Winters but in the long run what you
need is a plan that means that we don't
need to have to give very very expensive
support as taxpayers because we've got
an energy system that works better that
that deals with what dictators are doing
in other parts of the world it means
that we're not suddenly vulnerable to to
big changes in international gas prices
so I I want to outline the short-term
support that will give people who need
it but also a long-term plan to really
change our approach to energy
whole in the public finances that you
want to try and Shrink with a mixture of
tax Rises and spending cards it
well we do have to do some tax Rises do
some spending cuts if we're going to
show that we're a country that pays our
way and the reason for that is is very
simple you know we were able to help
businesses through the furlough scheme
we've been able to help people with
their energy bills this winter we'll be
able to do so next winter because we've
been responsible with public finances
we're now in a situation where the world
has changed very dramatically over the
last year
but the plan that we'll outline will
help us get through this in a way that I
I want to make sure that this recession
if we're in a recession is as short and
shallow as possible and get through to
the economy growing healthily the other
side and that's the plan
that I think will give people confidence
and that's what I want to announce to
the House of Commons you say that you've
been responsible with the public
finances I just want to question if
that's actually true um I think we can
look at a debt over time debt levels and
obviously I'd take your point that I'm
sure you'll say that you know covid has
come along and that has affected things
but actually the increase in debt
started before that you can see here you
know it's starting to go up from around
you know 2008 to 2009 and government
debt is a percentage of the economy has
been high for some time some people will
be saying hang on the conservatives have
been in power for 12 years you're the
ones who've actually effectively trashed
the economy and got it into the state
we're in now but we've had some very big
shocks as you mentioned a uh once in a
century pandemic now the situation in
Ukraine and and you'll find all
countries all over the world have seen
their debt levels increase in fact our
debt level is lower than many other
countries many other big countries
across the world but the question is not
the absolute level of debt so much as
whether you have a plan to bring it down
responsibly over time so that people can
see just as families have to make sure
that in the end they can pay their bills
they don't just max out on their credit
card without having any way of repaying
those debts it's just the same for
countries and we have to do that because
if we want to put more money into the
NHS if we want to help people are going
to find it very very difficult this
winter then we need to have the
resources to do that and that means that
we need to take difficult decisions even
at moments like this you've said that
all government departments will have to
find more efficiencies than planned so
is that true of every Department well a
strong Public Services which we all want
need a strong economy so you have to
take difficult decisions but it's also
true that a strong economy needs good
Public Services we need for example the
NHS to help people get back to work so
we'll approach this in a balanced way
that makes sure that we do everything we
can to keep the recession if we're in
one as short as possible and get the
economy growing as quickly as we can you
mentioned the NHS that I just want to
have a look at the latest figures for a
e at waiting times because this really
is
um pretty uh Stark this is the number of
people waiting more than 12 hours in a e
in England at four thousand forty three
thousand I should say 792
in October I mean frankly this doesn't
look like a Health Service that can find
efficiency savings this looks like a
Health Service that you know is on the
brink of collapse there are massive
pressures in the NHS obviously it's
something I know very well from previous
jobs I've done and I think that doctors
nurses on the front line are frankly
under unbearable pressure so I I do
recognize the picture you say it's also
true that there is a lot of money going
to the NHS and they will be the first to
say that in a context where funding for
the NHS is going up we need to do
everything we can to find efficiencies
but if you're saying to me the NHS is in
a very very tricky situation I agree and
you know I care passionately about the
NHS chess I spent more time thinking
about the NHS than any other public
service in my time in Parliament and we
need the NHS to help us get out of the
economic difficulties we're in because
as you'll see in other parts of the
Sunday papers we've got a big increase
in the number of people who aren't
working aren't taking part in work even
though they perhaps could and sometimes
that's as a result of long-term sickness
so the NHS is part of the solution as
well as facing some very big problems so
you're going to look at that
specifically to try and I guess look at
the benefit systems try and encourage
people back to work who you believe
could be working more we need to look at
all public services to make sure that
they're doing the right thing for the
economy we need to take these difficult
decisions but we need a balanced plan
and what I want to announce to the
country on Thursday is is not just the
difficult decisions but also to show the
way through and part of that is to show
that by tackling inflation early dealing
with these bills that are soaring for
families up and down the country we can
get back to Growing the economy
healthily so that we can invest the kind
of sums that we all want to in our
Public Services you talked at the
beginning about compassion and you've
also said that those with the broader
shoulders should be asked to Bear the
greatest burden how do you define people
with a broader shoulders
but I think we have to recognize that
people on the very lowest incomes
only have so much they can give we will
be asking everyone for sacrifices but I
think in a in a fair society as we are
in the UK we need to recognize that
there's only so much you can ask from
people on the very lowest income so that
will be reflected in the decisions that
I take and I think that's important
because Britain is a decent country a
fair country a compassionate country and
I want that to be reflected in the
decisions we take so you'll be paying a
bit more tax then after next week well
we're all going to be paying a bit more
tax I'm afraid Sophie
um but it's not just going to be bad
news I think what people recognize that
is that if you want to give people
confidence about the future you have to
be honest about the present and you have
to have a plan and this will be a plan
to help bring down inflation help
control high energy prices and also get
our way back to Growing healthily which
is what we need so much to those were
the broader shoulders include public
sector workers who were likely to be
seeing real terms cuts to their pay at a
time when inflation is a 10 well I'm
very conscious of the concerns for
example of nurses who are considering
industrial action at the moment and if
you listen to what nurses leaders say
their concern is about the impact of
inflation on their pay packet and the
point I would make conservatives know
that a thriving Dynamic economy needs
low taxes and sell money but sound money
has to come first because if you're a
nurse it's inflation that is eroding the
spending power in your pay packet it's
meaning that your weekly shop is
becoming much more expensive it's
meaning that mortgages are more
expensive than they were and so we need
to do something that shows public sector
workers just as we show everyone that
we're getting back to a low inflation
economy where they don't have to worry
about bills getting higher and higher do
you agree with the health secretary that
nurses are asking for too much well I
think we have to recognize
a difficult truth that if we gave
everyone
inflation-proof pay Rises inflation
would stay we wouldn't bring down
inflation and that's why you know I'm
not pretending there aren't some
difficult decisions but what I want to
say to to nurses to everyone is that the
way through this is to bring down
inflation as quickly as possible because
that is the root cause of your concern
your anger your frustration that your
pay isn't going as far as it might and
you know you talk about difficult
decisions and you know and everyone
being impacted but I just wonder if
that's true because you know according
to reports the triple auction pensions
will be protected so pensions will be
going up by 10 linked to inflation do
nurses have broader shoulders than you
know wealthy retirees spending time on
the golf course well I think these are
the questions you should ask me after I
announce what the decisions are next
week but
um I would say that there is a lot of
pensioner poverty a lot of pensioners in
very triple locks not means tested but
well very often pensioners need help and
it's not necessarily people on the very
lowest incomes but I think you have to
wait for the decisions and then we'll
see but I think what you'll see overall
is a broad approach that recognizes that
where we can we need to prioritize
people on the lowest incomes okay now
have you as you've acknowledged we are
most likely already in a recession
you're of course proposing to cut
spending and raise taxes two things that
can have a negative impact on growth I
just want to listen to in Duncan Smith
this is what he told our Deputy
political editor at Sam coats this week
if they try and hammers too hard with
tax Rises they will actually drive us
deeper into recession thus countering
the right objective and by the way any
deficit they think is there and by the
way these are just forecasts would
actually grow not shrink so they they
actually defeat the objective which is
what John Maynard Keynes told us many
years ago you don't raise taxes during a
course of a recession
he's worried that you could be driving
us deeper into recession is it right
well um I have a great deal of respect
for Ian Duncan Smith and um he
illustrates with some very important
points the very finely balanced decision
we have to make because he's absolutely
right you don't want to do things that
make any recession that you may be in
worse but on the other hand if if you do
nothing if you don't show that we're
going to bring our debt down over time
we've seen what happened before with the
the mini budget that happened interest
rates get higher and you get a recession
that's made worse because people
suddenly find the cost of their
mortgages are shot through the roof
businesses find that the cost of their
loans have become much more expensive so
you need to chart a balance course that
is doing the right thing to make sure
that the recession that we have by the
way the predicted fall in German GDP is
is much greater than the fall here so
this isn't something that's just US
inflation is higher in Germany in in
Italy as well so all countries are
facing these challenges but if you're
saying to me do I want to act in a way
that makes this recession if we're in it
as short and shallow as possible
absolutely he's not the only
conservative MP who will be concerned
about you know growth and about low
taxes I just want to play you a part of
our interview that we did when you were
running to be a conservative leader back
in July which feels like a lifetime ago
but it was only a few months this is a
message that you were giving then
we are where we are and I think the
priority now is to go for growth for the
economy but I also think no conservative
should raise taxes so the cut the cuts
I'll make they're not particularly
retail I'm also someone who thinks that
we shouldn't just stop the corporation
tax Rises I think we should cut them so
that they're the lowest in Europe and
North America I want to cut it to 15 the
lowest we're able we're allowed to cut
it to according to International
agreements
cutting taxes going for growth what
happened to that guy well he's sitting
right in front of you Sophie and um look
I actually overall point I was making is
something that I hope you'll see
reflected in the decisions made on
Thursday which is to try and protect the
things that really matter for economic
growth but the world has changed since
the summer we've had a very big
deterioration in public finances in the
international situation we wish you seen
that to be fair was during that
leadership campaign describing is
prioritizing growth over inflation it's
fantasy economics well and he deserves
great credit for that because because he
said things like that that people didn't
want to hear he lost the conservative
leadership campaign and I think
subsequent events have proved that he is
absolutely right in the judgments that
he made at that time but what I would
say is
um the Jeremy Hunt you saw there saying
let's be the most competitive place for
businesses anywhere in Europe is the
same Jeremy Hunt that is now chance of
the exchequer and we need to absolutely
protect the things that matter for our
long-term growth
um just finally
um you mentioned what you see like that
of course he used to do your job at
Chancellor and
you know what it is like you know
putting together a big fiscal event like
this with your boss the guy who used to
be Chancellor is a bit like someone
having someone you know looking over
your shoulder marking your homework for
you it's a great relief actually Sophie
because I've got someone who knows all
the things you can do that might go
wrong all the mistakes you you might
make inadvertently so we have exactly
the same approach on the big issues we
need to do what's right for long-term
growth we need to be prepared to take
difficult decisions if necessary but we
want to protect the vulnerable but in
terms of the detail this is someone
who's done my job extremely well and uh
that's a great support okay thank you
very much indeed thank you
the chancellor as speaking there ahead
of his Autumn statement which we are of
course expecting on Thursday well let's
turn to labor now shall we and find out
what they made of that interview with
the chancellor we can speak now to the
shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves who
joins us now from Leeds thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning
um Jeremy Hunt telling me there that
everyone is going to be paying a little
bit more tax after next week do you
think he's got the right plan
well we'll see what he comes up with on
Thursday but I am determined to hold him
to account for having a fair tax system
and what I would like to see on Thursday
and what I would be doing if I was
Chancellor of the exchequer is closing
some of the tax loopholes which means
today that some of the wealthiest in
society and some of the uh most uh
biggest businesses are not paying their
fair share of taxes that's why for
example when the when the Prime Minister
flies off to the G20 Summit today he
should be committing to closing some of
those loopholes that mean big Global
multinationals not paying their fair
share of tax there is already a global
agreement but we haven't legislated for
it here in the UK and it could bring in
7 billion pounds a year as well as
helping some of our smaller businesses
and High Street businesses as you know
Sophie I've been banging on about the
windfall tax on big energy companies
since the beginning of this year and the
Prime Minister when he was Chancellor
slow peddled on that we still think that
you could raise an additional 50 billion
pounds through extending the windfall
tax by about two years by back dating it
to the beginning of January when those
windfalls those profits of War started
coming onto the balance sheets of the
energy companies by getting rid of some
of the loopholes that mean companies
like shell are not even paying any of
the government's energy profits Levy and
they're extending it to some of the
electricity generators so there are fair
choices that the chancellor could be
making this week rather than just
putting all of that burden on ordinary
working people who are already
struggling with the highest inflation
that any of us have experienced for 40
years and now risk more of their money
going in taxes rather than having it for
the weekly food shop the higher mortgage
payments and everything else that is
facing people right now and I take your
point that labor was of course the first
to call for the windfall tax they're on
energy firms but it does look like
according to reports that the government
is going to be extending uh that uh next
week Jeremy Hunt was also talking about
the cops let me just say let me just
let me just say it on a win for tax I
hope the government does extend it but I
hope they do what labor are calling for
which is ensuring that the tax paid by
energy companies here is similar to what
it is in Norway and that we get rid of
those loopholes that mean for more
investment in fossil fuels those energy
companies can offset the windfall tax
that is not right companies should be
paying their fair share and that would
ease the pressure on the tax burden for
ordinary working people okay the
question that I was going to ask was
that Jeremy Hunt was also talking about
the cost of the energy support package
saying that with the rise in energy
bills it's going to be like funding a
second NHS so I just wonder what Labor's
plan is how long do you think the energy
price guarantee should last and is there
a point when actually it should be
targeted at the most vulnerable
pensioners those on low incomes rather
than just everybody
well when um Kia Stormer and me set out
our plans for the Autumn um winter
months and we did that in August at that
time the conservatives were all saying
um that they didn't believe in in
handouts they're constantly playing
catch up with what labor are putting
forward and of course the new Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt would reduce the support
that was available to people now look
we'll see where we are going into the
new year and where energy uh prices are
but labor have always been very clear
that the windfall tax on energy
companies should be used to try and keep
bills as low as possible for pensioners
for families and also for businesses and
you know I speak to many businesses
including here in Leeds and in fact I
was talking to one business owner
yesterday who said that she wasn't even
able to get a contract for energy so she
doesn't know from one week to the next
what she's paying because she's now just
on a floating a deal tracking Energy
prices that's incredibly difficult for
her and her business because energy
costs are a big part of it so we need
more certainty and Clarity from the
government you're not giving us what is
going to be available after after April
you're not giving the certainty in
Clarity either though are you because I
just asked you know firstly if you think
it should be targeted and secondly how
long it would last for under labor
well I I've made this commitment that we
would extend the uh windfall tax on
those big oil and gas companies and
we've always said that if you do that
there's more money to help people with
their gas and electricity uh bills and
the government have always slow pedaled
on the support that is needed it's why
also labor came up with a package for
some of our most energy intensive
Industries who are being put a
comparative disadvantage compared with
some of our International competitors
who are being supported and the
government has never come up with a
package to help them
in September you said on GMB austerity
is not the right approach we will oppose
any cuts to Public Services is that
still your position that you will oppose
any cuts to Public Services
public services are already on their
knees seven million people are waiting
for an NHS operation uh or or support
um you know if you look at our schools
our class sizes are increasing teachers
are increasingly having to fund at the
basics out of their own money and so I I
don't believe that austerity 2.0 after
the austerity that we've gone through
after the last 12 years it is the right
approach which is why I'm arguing for
two things both fairer choices on taxes
but also crucially a plan for growth
because one of the reasons that we are
in this mess we're in and why we have
been so uniquely exposed in Britain with
one of the lowest growths of any of the
oecd the major industrialized economies
is because we've just been languishing
in the league tables in growth over the
last decade so we need a growth plan
it's why I've set out Labor's green
Prosperity plan because I genuinely only
believe that Britain can be a global
leader in some of the industries of the
future from Green hydrogen to tidal
energy floating offshore winds carbon
capture and storage creating good jobs
in all parts of Britain helping keep
people's bills low and also boosting our
energy security it's why we're set out
our plans to make Britain the best place
to start and grow a business and
reforming business rates to help our
small businesses and our high streets
Thrive we need all of that because
that's what brings in the money to pay
for our public services and the problem
is now after 12 years of conservative
government growth is on the floor and
inflation is going through the roof I'm
going to jump in just because I've got a
couple more questions that I do want to
squeeze in before I have to let you go
and Jeremy Hunt was saying on a public
sector pay and on strikes if we gave
everyone inflation-proof pay Rises then
inflation would stay at nurses currently
striking they want an above inflation
pay rise of 17 do you think that's
affordable
I'm not going to pluck numbers out of
the air but it should be awesome that's
on the table the conservatives
well it's up to the pay review bodies to
work with the unions but it is a badge
of shame that for the first time in
their history nurses are looking to go
on strike this didn't happen when labor
was in government because we valued and
respected Public Service workers
including those who work in our NHS
who've given so much to our country
these last few years we've got huge
recruitment challenges in the NHS
including amongst nurses at workload
issues issues of stress we've got nurses
that are going to food banks so we need
to support our NHS workers including our
nurses and that means fair but
affordable pay Rises I'm not going to
cut into the uh the pay review
negotiations that are going uh on but
the Secretary of State for health should
meet with the nurses and the nursing
unions and work out a deal and and show
some respect to these crucial Public
Service workers
I've just got one more question to
squeeze in
um over the summer you were pictured uh
chatting at to Rishi sunak at a
Bloomberg a drinks event it was shortly
before he was made prime minister
what were we talking about
uh well we were at a reception and uh I
shadowed and Richie soon at for about a
year and a half uh we've talked about a
number of things but it also
particularly actually about our children
we both got young children we were
talking about the influence that they
have on our politics
um I was also you know commiserating
with him on on losing the leadership
contest uh he did lose that contest to
Liz truss is now prime minister but he's
not willing to face the people there
should be a general election because he
has no mandates he was not chosen by
either his members and certainly not by
the country there's no mandate for the
cuts and the tax increases that they are
putting through now the people should
have a choice about who their prime
minister and who their Chancellor is
that will only come through a general
election and that's why we desperately
need one to have a mandate for the
decisions that are being made in our
name uh thank you very much indeed
Rachel Reeves the safe space I feel talk
about children in the political Arena
Arena
what you were watching at safe Ridge on
Sunday we've had I think a bit of
information there from the chancellor
and what to expect next week tax Rises
for everyone although I wouldn't hold
your breath on those inflation busting
public sector wage Rises still to come
on the program this morning in just a
moment we'll be talking to the foreman
leveling up secretary under Liz truss
Simon Clark the first time he's given an
interview since leaving government
and then later we'll hear from Christina
mcinay I wonder what she makes of the
Jeremy Hunt interview she's the boss of
the UK's biggest Union Unison plus we're
going to be getting some immediate
reaction from our Deputy political
editor Sam coats been watching all our
interviews this morning we are going to
speak to Sam a bit later and get his
take
[Music]
now Simon Clark was one of Liz truss's
closest allies so he had a ringside seat
at the formation of the economic policy
that was to bring her down he back Boris
Johnson initially in the contest to
replace her so he was quickly out as
leveling up secretary when Rishi sunak
took the top job he's also been Chief
Secretary of the Treasury and criticized
the signs of the state so what does he
want to see from the chancellor on
Thursday thank you very much for being
on the program this morning at Mr Clark
I'm not sure if you managed to catch any
of Jeremy Hunter interview but he did
say that we can all expect to be paying
a bit more tax do you think he's got the
right approach
uh yes I think it is absolutely right
that we balance the books I would urge
Jeremy to make sure that we do as much
as we can from spending reductions as
opposed to tax increases noting that
clearly taxes at a very high level and
faced with the recession risk that we
all know uh exists at the moment I I
think the balance of advantage and the
best pro-growth option would be to
reduce spending rather than to increase
taxes but I recognize he's got a
incredibly difficult job to do and he
will have my support in making sure that
we strike an arrangement which will give
the markets confidence and the country
confidence that we can pay our way in
the world
you say that you'd like to see the
balance slightly tipped in favor of
spending reductions at the same time
though a lot of Public Services are
already under pretty deep strain whether
it's you know the NHS whether it's
schools whether it's defense are there
any areas where there are more
efficiency savings if you like to be
found
my I think the main thing is I would say
that we should protect the defense
budget at a time when obviously the
world is in turmoil when we're seeing
the effects of Putin's war and when we
know that China is keeping an eye firmly
on what opportunities may exist for her
with Taiwan so I would urge him not to
cut the defense budget and to stick by
Liz's three percent commitment of GDP by
the end of the decade but beyond that I
think there are areas where we can make
savings I think that our capital
investment programs are significantly
over committed I think there is a real
issue with underspends across a lot of
government because of the impact of
covid and as a result there is the
potential there to realize tens of
billions of savings without cutting
crucially vital Public Services
at the same time though aren't those
kind of capital product projects quite
important for growth
well some of them can be I mean
obviously some of them don't need to be
necessarily cut they can be canceled uh
but they can also be deferred in terms
of the time scale for these projects so
it doesn't necessarily need to be the
case that you uh end them entirely but
you can say that we'll reprofile them in
terms of when they will come on stream
and that offers obviously considerable
savings potential I think something like
hs2 obviously we've seen Rel passenger
numbers have not recovered to
pre-pandemic levels particularly for
commuter travel there are real questions
about schemes like this which I think
ought to be addressed first before we
cut things like defends before we cut
things obviously which really matter to
the public and I think that is the the
challenge obviously that Jeremy has to
face but my own view is having obviously
spent most of the last year as Chief
Secretary of the Treasury the the
opportunity in this statement is really
to reprofile our Capital spend so that
we can we can get to a better a more
sustainable place I really would urge
him to be very careful about cutting
some of the things though which would go
to the heart of our national security
um I want to talk a bit about tax Rises
because it was pretty clear that there
are going to be a significant tax Rises
next week whether it's more High earners
paying the 45p rate whether it's
millions of people being effectively
paying more tax because of freezers to
income levels now Ian Duncan Smith told
Sky News that if the government tries to
hammer us too hard with tax Rises they
will actually drive us deeper into
recession do you agree with that
well one of the reasons uh clearly as I
supported Liz in the summer was that I
believe very strongly that you know with
the tax burden it's a 70-year high we
need to be extremely careful about about
further increasing the challenges facing
businesses and households and you know
that is something which I know Jeremy is
an entrepreneur will be very conscious
of I'm not saying there are easy answers
here and I certainly don't want to uh uh
to try to to sort of try and suggest
that the chancellor is is is is faced
with uh with with straightforward
options but what I do think is that we
we have throughout this exercise to be
incredibly aware of just how much we've
asked of both the British public and
British industry ever recent years
obviously corporation tax is going to go
up from 19 to 25 that's a heck of an
increase I think family budgets are
obviously as we all know under great
pressure because of the impact of the
inflation arising from the war in
Ukraine I would therefore as I say
strongly urge that the great balance of
this statement should come from spending
reductions because I really do think
that uh there is there is an issue with
our raising uh the burden of Taxation on
Britain at this time
now there's been a huge change of
Direction since the list trust
Administration that of course you were
such a key at part of on individual
policies such as the 45p rate of tax but
also on the general philosophy as well
you know Liz truss wanted to borrow to
fund growth Jeremy Hunt and Rishi sunak
are all about you know raising the tax
burden and cutting spending in order to
bring down um the deficit even in a
recession is there a risk do you think
that we're now swinging too far the
other way to overcompensate for what
came before
well look I mean I I think it is
absolutely imperative that we restore
Market confidence in this country and
it's it is it is it is right that the
government uh makes this statement this
week and shows a clear path to make our
our debt sustainable we've we've been
through an extraordinary series of
events uh the government has acted
rightly uh to make sure that we protect
British households but we have as a
result got ourselves into what is a very
difficult situation and one which is
obviously shared by most other uh
Western economies have also had to act
uh to protect uh households and
businesses I do think that in this
exercise but we must be careful not to
choke off growth that would be my main
my main argument I don't dispute the
need uh to restore Market confidence I
think it's very important that we do set
out a clear a clear runway for years
ahead but as I say I think I think that
if we're if if you're faced with two
difficult choices the better choice is
to curb public spending let's not forget
that government spending as a whole has
risen from some
700 billion in 2010 when the
conservatives came to office to over a
trillion pounds today so it has risen
very substantially over the course of
the last decade there is the potential
there I believe to make savings which
don't damage public services and which
fundamentally allow us to achieve the
results that we need to uh while also
allowing a pro-growth policy to to be
delivered
now I've got to ask this because I feel
like many people listening to you will
be asking you know this question you you
were part of the Liz truss core team the
quad if you like and that was the team
that effectively you know trashed the
economy the bank of England had to step
in after the budget at the chancellor
was let go the Prime Minister became the
shortest serving ever prime minister in
the UK
why should people listen to what you
have to say
well I I I would reject the idea that uh
what's happened in the economy is
primarily uh the result of what of the
actions that Liz took the the reality is
that a third of the global economy is
now in recession we are faced with
extraordinary headwinds uh coming out of
uh the situation in Ukraine which has
driven inflation to levels uh which we
haven't seen in my lifetime that
obviously comes on top of the legacy of
the pandemic not just the debt that we
incurred but also the uh the enormously
challenging society and economic
consequences that we're still feeling uh
and and interest rates are rising the
world over as a result I completely
accept uh that mistakes were made with
the timing of the mini budget and whilst
I take my share of responsibility as one
of Liz's cabinet ministers I obviously
wasn't directly uh the the driver of
some of the choices that were made about
whether or not to hold a new spending
review for example which was something
that I had urged during the summer which
I I understood was the basis if you the
action that would be taken but look
nonetheless I do not resign from the
fundamental proposition that Liz set out
which is that this economy our society
as a whole needs to become more
economically Dynamic more successful if
we are to sustain the Public Services on
which people rely and to pay our way in
a world where frankly the West needs to
be more competitive if we're to keep up
with emerging emerging economies that
was Liz's fundamental Insight I think it
is right I think it is very important
that as the government seeks to address
the undoubted challenges that the UK
economy faces that we don't do things
that cut across that fundamental Mission
which is that our country needs to be a
successful place to operate a business
to grow uh businesses large and small
and that that will not happen in the
burden of Taxation continues to increase
um
quasiquating
um the former Chancellor of course under
Liz truss gave an interview this week
where he says that he warned Liz truss
about going too fast is that your
recollection of things
well I I obviously wasn't privy to the
individual conversations between Liz and
quasi and it's it's not really for me to
interpose myself into the discussion of
who said what when I have the greatest
respect for both Liz and for quasi and I
think the way events have played out
obviously uh it has it perhaps been
somewhat reductive uh and somewhat
caricatured in terms of the positions
that that were adopted as I say I
believe there would be a full spending
review to a company uh the the tax cuts
that Liz wanted to make I think that
would have been the way of showing the
markets that we wanted to transition to
a lower tax more Dynamic economy but
that we had a clear plan to do so linked
to reductions in public spending that uh
was certainly the position that we had
discussed during the summer and I
believe it would have been a way of
making Liz's fundamental Mission more
sustainable uh and that that that is
obviously a lasting regret uh that I
hold but do I think as I say that what
Liz was saying about growth remains true
I absolutely do and I have a lot of
respect for the courage that she showed
in trying to move the debate onto ground
which I think is essential for the
long-term health of our economy
when was the last time you spoke to Liz
truss and how was she
uh well I I saw uh Liz at the the the
farewell Gathering that she held at
Checkers last month and I'm going to see
her again uh this week but she is
remarkably uh resilient she's always
been exceptionally dignified and there's
no there's no self-pity there there is
obviously regret and we all share uh
regret for what happened and uh you know
I I certainly uh continue to regard Liz
as both a a great colleague and a good
friend and someone who as I say I think
has fundamentally got her her
perspective on what this country needs
to do right uh we we obviously all uh
have to look back and learn the lessons
of what happened in the Autumn but
ought the message to go out that Britain
can should be a high tax High regulation
economy as labor wants it to be and that
that is the route to success I'm afraid
uh that that is not true now it wasn't
true then and we have to be very careful
as we seek to balance the books in this
country that we do remember that
competitiveness internationally is the
watch word against which ultimately uh
all our actions ought to be judged okay
thank you uh very much uh indeed Simon
Clark there in t-site thank you
now as usual the take will follow this
program it's just after 9 30. our chance
to analyze today's interviews talk
through any news lines with our Deputy
political editor at Sam coats but we can
get a quick take from Sam now on what
stood out to him already uh this morning
at morning Sam good to uh see you do you
think we've got a little bit more
knowledge about what to expect next week
absolutely Sophie the world has changed
that's Jeremy Hunt's message to you to
the country this morning as he prepares
what is clearly going to be a gruesome
statement uh that he delivers on behalf
of Rishi sunak and the government on
Thursday interestingly not everybody
agrees as you were just hearing from
Simon Clark senior figure from the trust
government who worries that actually
this might go too far uh a huge row
clearly Brewing inside the conservative
party about whether or not Jeremy Hunt
and Rishi sunak are going to be doing
the right thing with swinging tax Rises
and cuts to public services in the year
ahead but what really really struck me
Sophie about your interview with Jeremy
Hunt was the sheer number of promises he
was making in passing he wants a
recession that that isn't too deep he
wants to make sure that nobody cannot
Heat their homes he promises help for
businesses with energy bills next winter
as well as this one there's a long list
of guarantees he seems to be given how
does he square that with having no money
okay Sam a very good question thank you
very much for your analysis as always
and we'll speak a bit later
now the nation will fall silent today at
11AM to remember all of those who have
given their lives for this country in
Conflict since the first world war the
service at the cenotaph in London will
be particularly poignant because it is
going to be the first led by the king
since the passing of his late Majesty uh
the queen now our security and defense
editor Deborah Haynes spoke to the chief
of the defense staff Admiral Sir Tony
radakin for this program they discussed
the war in Ukraine and also pressures on
defense spending but she began by asking
about remembrance
I think remembrance Sunday is always
poignant I think it's poignant for the
whole nation this special moment when we
pause to reflect on the sacrifice and
commitment of others to provide our
freedom today
I think there's a special poignancy this
year with both the loss of her majesty
another loss of a second world war
veteran
and I also think it's poignant when we
have once again the Specter of war in
Europe and all that that entails and a
country that's been invaded and is
fighting for its freedom we're
remembering the um those who gave their
lives in the first and the second world
wars and like you said right now Europe
has War once again on its soil How
likely is it that this could actually
escalate into the Third World War
I think what you've seen we're
approaching now nearly nine months
is that the war is relatively contained
in terms of geography
the impact of the war is enormous that's
Global the impact on food prices the
impact on millions of people and whether
or not they were going to get the grain
that Ukraine provides the impact on all
of us whether it's inflation or the
energy crisis and I think those are all
a reminder that even though the war
itself might be relatively physically
contained what it means is millions of
people that have been displaced from
their country millions of people that
are being attacked and they're losing
their energy or their water doesn't work
anymore millions of people fighting for
their freedom that's what you're seeing
and tens of thousands of people that are
dying or are injured and and it's that
reminder that these precious values of
of freedom of democracy of that your
territory is your own and that when
that's attacked then the right people
defend those and they fight to get them
back
we're talking
um just after Russia has given this
order to withdraw its treats from
Hearthstone City in the south of Ukraine
how significant is that
I think it's significant in the sense
that once again you're seeing Russia
fail Russia's failed on all of its
strategic objectives it wanted to
subjugate Ukraine the opposite is hap
has happened Ukraine is fighting for its
freedom it wanted to take control of the
Cities you saw that fail it wanted to to
weaken NATO NATO is stronger and now
you're seeing a war that inevitably at
the Tactical level has twists and turns
but you're seeing a Russia under
pressure
taking Desperate Measures that's why
he's had to mobilize additional people
but it's it's got to try and overcome
a nation that's fighting for its freedom
a nation that we're supporting alongside
lots of other International countries
whether that's cash whether that's
Armament whether that's ammunition
for your U.S counterpart
um General Mark milley has said that the
withdrawal um in her son could provide a
window of opportunity for negotiations
between the two sides what do you think
I think that those windows will be
determined by
president zielinski and President Putin
and undoubtedly the Tactical events
might open those windows a little bit
more
but we've got to respect that Ukraine is
fighting for its territory its future
its survival
and this is a success for Ukraine but at
the same time Ukraine continues to be
attacked Ukraine has lost ground that it
needs to win back Ukraine has got
millions of people that are not living
in their homes they're either living
elsewhere in Ukraine or in the rest of
Europe they've got millions of people
that are suffering from the impacts of
the electrical infrastructure having
been attacked or the water
infrastructure being attacked it is a
war crime to to a to to deliberately
attack civilians and and that's what's
still going on is there any change in
your assessment on the likelihood of
Russia backed into a corner resorting to
a nuclear strike in Ukraine I think
we've got to be really careful of of of
Reckless rhetoric where
where the these noises are made about
about nuclear whether it's a dirty bomb
or it's a tactical nuclear weapon we
should be really careful about that
language that would be another
total
horrific step and we don't see that that
we're on a pathway to to that to that
particular Specter and we've also got to
be really clear that if we started to go
down that path that it would lead to
incredibly serious consequences but
where none of us are on that path and
Russia I think has tried to to reassure
in that sense and I think we've been
really clear as to how dangerous that
that particular route would be
um Sky News reported this week about
about
claims that Russia has transported
captured British and law anti-tank
missiles
U.S anti-tank javelins and U.S Stinger
anti-aircraft missiles to Iran along
with loads of cash 122 million pounds
worth in cash in exchange for dozens of
drones these deadly Shah head drones
that they've been used that Russia's
been using in Ukraine were you aware of
this so I went I won't go into the
detail of intelligence reports but we've
always been aware that when we provide
some of our weaponry and it's going into
a war zone there's a risk that that
Weaponry might be captured and and so
what I can offer you is that the the
technology that we're talking about is
technology of 20 30 years ago and then
that technology is used in the
manufacturing process to provide the
weapons of today and and so I we're
conscious that when we provide Armament
and support to a Ukraine that's in in a
war then there might be some of those
weapons that end up being captured and
that's taken into account when we'll go
through our assessment as to what's
going to be provided so are you going to
do anything about it if Iran is trying
to develop end-laws
so we're in a constant competition with
certain Nations it's it's very much the
case with Iran but it's
it's a it's a fact that when you provide
your weapons to to Country X
in the middle of a war they may not
necessarily stay in country X the
chancellor is going to be giving his
Autumn statement on Thursday how
confident are you that defense will be
protected from the impact of inflation
and foreign exchange
I can't go into the detail of of a
financial statement statement that's
that's that's going to be announced
later this week but what I can
offer you is the seriousness with which
the situation is being discussed we have
a prime minister he's been prime
minister for just over two weeks he's
had numerous conversations with the
defense secretary with me about the
security situation in Europe but also
the globe but we specifically had an
hour with the Prime Minister and the
chancellor and I accompanied the defense
secretary
to talk about
what would be the impact of a financial
settlement and and to the the richness
and the seriousness of that conversation
recognizing that this war in Europe is
part of the reason why we have the level
of inflation that we have and why we
have the economic pressure and therefore
in trying to deal with the economic
pressure
we need to acknowledge that at its core
is this security pressure in Europe and
and the government is is having the
right level of conversation to try and
manage that but also manage the security
situation into the future so that's why
you're seeing a conversation about
coming back to the integrated review of
last year and and and taking time to to
assess that again what what what what is
working what do we want to affirm and
what might we want to adjust and and
recognize because of the increased
aggression of Russia we we need to
adjust some of the risks that we were
taking and that might mean in the longer
term more investment but let's have that
com that that longer term conversation
as well the government keeps saying
there needs to be economic stability in
order to have things like defense
spending do you think they're now
realizing that there cannot be economic
stability without security and in terms
of having security you need therefore to
invest fully in defense
absolutely and I think you saw that with
last year's integrated review an
integrated review that tried to take
that inject integration review that's
not going to be funded unless this
government gives you a
Elian Powell pounds according to the
defense secretary himself over the next
two years are you going to get this 8
billion pounds so I can't I can't I
can't go into the specifics but what
happens if you don't get it so again I I
think it will be wrong to to start
talking about if we don't get it then it
means this this and this those
conversations are being had with the
Prime Minister and the chancellor their
private conversations I can assure you
that those conversations are being had
they're the right conversations and
they're being blended with what was said
in last year's integrated review what
needs to be shaped for the longer term
future but also to recognize the the
immediate economic pressure of the
country is under but also recognized as
a war in Europe and that that the the
seriousness of those conversations are
being had and that's the Assurance I can
give you I'm sure they're serious but if
they don't end up with with eight
billion pounds for defense over the next
two years then they're meaningless it
means defense has to shrink would you
resign if that happens so so we've got
to wait and see what the Autumn
statement says I think we've got to be
really cautious of of of of of the risk
of being a bit too shrill and saying
right if if this happens then I'm going
to yeah yeah this person is going to
resign and that I I'm much more in their
space of the right conversations are
being had let's wait and see what the
Autumn statement says let's take stock
then let's recognize there's a blend
going on of economic pressures that have
to be serviced and security pressures
that have to be service and the right
conversations are being had to allow to
allow those solutions to emerge
foreign
's there speaking to the chief of the
defense staff on Remembrance Sunday
well we heard that warning from Jeremy
Hunter on the program this morning that
we'll all pay a bit more tax and there
will be what he calls very difficult
decisions on public spending too with
nurses due to go on strike across the
NHS soon and more strikes in the public
sector I can now speak to the general
secretary at the UK's biggest Union
Unison which represents more than a
million public sector workers that is
Christina mcenay and she joins us now
thank you for being on the program this
morning
um Jeremy Hunt said the NHS can find
efficiencies is he right
uh I'm sure that any organization can
still find an element of efficiency
savings but I think it's a bit of a one
of these words that that's a bit of a
red flag to many public sector workers
because it so often means cuts and
that's the worry is that the NHS is
basically on its needs at the moment uh
I've been spending the the past week
going around speaking to our members
across the country you listen people who
are paramedics and nurses and uh theater
staff in hospitals and I can tell you
that they don't drink there's much room
for any efficiency savings what they
want to see is more investment in the
NHS they want to see a pay rate that
actually encourages people to join the
NHS and crucially to stay in the NHS
the latest figures that we showed to
Jeremy Hunt on any waiting time and show
at records number of people waiting more
than four hours and the number waiting
more than 12 hours was up 30 to almost
44
000. what kind of impact could spending
restraint have on the NHS could it be
dangerous
of course okay then what we I mean
you've just said to yourself that um
waiting listed at an all-time high we've
got um the biggest highest level of
public dissatisfaction with the NHS
since it started we've got 135 000
vacancies in the NHS and you know people
are waiting in ambulances outside
hospitals from five six seven as long as
10 hours but you're basically using
ambulances as another room of the
hospital which is not really an
efficient use of of ambulances and this
will have it's already having an impact
on British people and it will just only
get worse you know when I hear College
sessions talk about you know difficult
choices to be made of course that's true
but there's also difficult choices what
difficult things will happen if we don't
make the right choices if they don't
make the right choices and one of those
will be the NHS is is almost ready to
collapse and excuse me for sounding like
a conspiracy theaters but I've had so
many people say it now is this a partly
a delivery attempt by the government to
run down the NHS in order to turn around
and say we'll have to bring in some
private organizations around it now I
hope that's not and a bit of me thanks
that's not what they're doing but what
they're not doing is taking the right
choices about investing in our public
services and it doesn't make sense
economically either
um because with it we've had what 12
years of near enough austerity or public
sector pay freezers and what's happened
the country hasn't grown the economy
hasn't grown uh you know the Dreadful
experiment that we had was then Liz
trust where she tried to just ramp all
of that up just showed what a bad
strategy that is and actually if you
invest in the working people of this
country if you see them as wealth
generators and you actually give them
decent paying pay to be able to generate
that wealth then that makes a difference
to local economies and that's how you
generate the you get the economy back
and speak again
I just want to come in because do you
really believe that the government is
deliberately trying to run the NHS down
because I feel like there are some
people in government who might find that
you know a bit offensive
I'm sure and as I said you know I don't
like to go conspiracy theaters but I
honestly sometimes when I go around and
I see what's happening in some of their
the nhas when I hear stories from people
who are working Unison members who are
working as nurses paramedics uh when I
hear what they have to tell me a bit of
me does think what is going on here How
can any pole session allow this to
happen uh you know to something that is
so valued by the British public so no
I'm not saying for definite that's
what's happening but every now and then
it does enter my mind at that maybe
what's happening I suspect I would
absolutely hope Jeremy Hunt certainly
doesn't think that given his views on
the NHS but I think sometimes to sort of
blame everything on you know external
other world affairs like Ukraine is
wrong because the problems in the NHS
and the social care sector were were
well known long before the Ukraine
crisis happened uh you know it's not
been wages that are pushing up inflation
and some of the decisions are taking
just a couple of months ago by the by
the Tory government have certainly made
things worse and none of the people I
represent in unison who do these
essential Public Services we're
responsible for any of that but they
will now be the ones being told we can't
give you more money because the
countries in such a state well I'm sorry
but politicians have to decide whether
they're going to spend their money
that's what they're paid to do is take
those difficult decisions let's let's
talk about uh money
um because of course there are the pay
negotiations uh going on you know given
the fact that you know as you accept
money is really short in the NHS are you
worried that it could lead to dangerous
outcomes
is it really right that the Royal
College of Nursing is asking for a 17
pay rise
well that's what the Royal College and
asking for and you know they've now got
a yes vote in a large number of uh uh
any large parts of the NHS to take
industrial action we're balloting our
members over 300 000 in the NHS who uh
air ballot closes on the 25th of
November and we're asking them to vote
Yes for strike action too so we will
definitely talking and working with the
Royal College of Nursing we get a esport
too there aren't pay negotiations going
on I'm afraid it's sad to say uh you
know ministers are telling us there's no
more money there's nobody sitting down
to discuss this with us and what I keep
seeing is a straight's not inevitable in
the NHS Australia's not inevitable
anywhere a strength is a symptom of a
problem it's not in itself because of a
problem and I would Arch Jeremy Hunt and
other government ministers to sit down
with the trade unions and actually talk
to us about how we can solve this
the house secretary Steve Barkley
described a 17 pay Rises neither
reasonable nor affordable is that kind
of the kind of level that Unison might
be asking for as well
we're looking for an inflation-proofed
pay award I think it's really important
that staff get something that actually
means they can stay in in work and look
at other families at the same time you
know they offer that that they offer the
award that has been made to NHS workers
in England Wales and Northern Ireland is
a 1400 pounds flat rate now for most
nurses that represents and most nurses
and people in that professional brand if
you like me call them within the NHS but
most of them it represents between four
and four point two percent inflation is
now running well over yeah over 10
expected to be even go as high as 12
that cannot be rate that we're expecting
these workers to continue to do their
job a very demanding job and yet take
what is an effect to Peak on and no
wonder so many of them are leaving the
sector you know they're going to take
jobs elsewhere you know you look at what
happens in the retail sector uh Tesco
Asda Sainsbury's little all the have all
given their staff at least two and in
some places three pay entrances this
year now if the government the
government answer to us is always we've
implemented the peer review body report
them through and that's true but what
they could do is reconvene the peer
review body to actually say to them
things have changed drastically since
they took their decision to award 1400
pounds and actually ask them to
reconsider and see what would be a fair
offer to give to public sector workers
and indeed NHS workers okay thank you
very much indeed for being on the
program this morning Christina mcino
there of unison
thank you
well that is it for this week's safety
Ridge on Sunday but in a moment after
the break we'll be running through
today's interviews and having a little
talk about what we've learned with
adaptive political editor Sam coats
thank you very much for joining us this
Sunday morning
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ridge on Sunday the take where we take
you back through the mornings interviews
with some analysis as well from our
Deputy political editor Sam coats to who
is joins us again this Sunday oh good to
see you Sam it's still always
interesting these interviews isn't it
before the kind of big fiscal events
because of course there is a limit on
what the chancellor is going to say it's
very controlled they're not going to
brief anything out or even give too much
hints about things they don't want to
talk about
but I felt this morning we did get a
pretty good steer from where Jeremy
hunts think he was and what to expect on
on Thursday there was a lot of pitch
rolling uh wasn't there what did you
make of it
that's right and by concentrating
actually on the principles behind what
Jeremy Hunt and racism are going to try
and do on Thursday so if he lovely I
think you learned a lot in that
interview let's just pause to look at
the very very biggest picture here
though and and this is where I think the
trouble might lie for Jeremy Hunt
um what happened in the last six weeks
is that the British political system the
conservative party ejected a prime
minister because their Economic Policy
went too far basically Liz trust wanted
to borrow too much in order to promote
growth and and I wonder whether or not
the conversation after Thursday Sophie
is whether or not Rishi sunak and Jeremy
Ann haven't done sort of the same thing
but in the other direction whether or
not the eye watering kind of pain that
they're going to initiate on Thursday
doesn't go too far whether it's
commensurate with the size of the
problem that we've got and I was very
struck that a very senior former cabinet
minister and Liz truss's government
there sounding the warning against tax
Rises against
um uh many of the things that we expect
uh Jeremy Hunt to announce on Thursday
and it's all underscores the fact that
we are making as a country we are having
a leadership of a conservative party
government that is zigzagging at speed
with its Economic Policy it's boring to
invest one week it is cutting to cl to
cut our cloth to our means uh the next
and it's no surprise that people's heads
are spinning and that very depressing
very gloomy interview with Jeremy Hunt
in which he emphasized the world has
changed so he has to bring in a lot of
pain I mean you know I think that would
worry people including Tory MPS let's
have a listen to Jeremy Hunt at this
point shall we Sam we'll come back to
you in just a moment but let's have a
listen to what Jeremy Hunt uh said to me
earlier
the world has changed since the summer
we've had a very big deterioration in
public finances in the international
situation we wish you soon like to be
fair was during that leadership campaign
describing as prioritizing growth over
inflation is fantasy economics well and
he deserves great credit for that
because because he said things like that
that people didn't want to hear he lost
the conservative leadership campaign and
I think subsequent events have proved
that he is absolutely right in the
judgments that he made at that time but
what I would say is
um the Jeremy Hunt you saw there saying
let's be the most competitive place for
businesses anywhere in Europe is the
same Jeremy Hunt that is now chance of
the exchequer
at the same job you hunt at their as
during that leadership at campaign
interview he says the world has changed
although of course uh Rishi Scenic was
also talking at that time about the risk
of inflation and saying that there had
to be at high taxes as a result uh now
it does seem doesn't it as though the
policy certainly has a shift as Sam was
saying it's almost like giving everyone
a little bit of you know um of neck her
bracing because it will come to whip
Whiplash Whiplash that's what I was
going for Scott just told me in my ear
um Whiplash is the word I was going for
as we are spinning around trying to keep
up uh with uh the conservative uh policy
because Jeremy Hunt told me this morning
that every one of us is going to be
paying higher taxes after Thursday let's
have a listen
well we're all going to be paying a bit
more tax I'm afraid Sophie
um but it's not just going to be bad
news I think what people recognize that
is that if you want to give people
confidence about the future you have to
be honest about the present and you have
to have a plan and this will be a plan
to help bring down inflation help
control high energy prices and also get
our way back to Growing healthily which
is what we need so much
well let's bring Sam back in shall we I
guess this is all about isn't it trying
to restore that reputation for fiscal
responsibility that the conservatives
have traditionally enjoyed
yes with two sets of pain so if it's
probably important to acknowledge both
there's going to be 10 tax Rises as uh
he said there but also big spending cuts
and pressure to keep down public sector
pay now he's going to tell nurse if he
made clear that the reason that you
can't do big public sector pay Rises is
because you've got to push down price
Rises push down inflation well it waits
to see whether or not nurses and other
bits the public sector buy that argument
and effectively call off some of the
strikes that uh nurses certainly and
other bits the public sector are talking
about because now the priority is
managing the economy trying to uh avoid
this sense that we had while Liz trust
was prime minister that actually we
can't afford some of the things that she
was promising and that's why we need the
pain and it's really interesting to look
at just how much already the political
landscape has changed and I I just go
really fascinating a little bit of
polling here which makes clear uh just
where all of a sudden now we've got a
new prime minister of the sort of
economic challenge lies for this
government and for the labor opposition
and if you look here this is essentially
about how much people trust the main
political figures so when you look at
the question of managing the economy
actually Rishi sunak beats kirst armor
50 to 39 so that's a really big
turnaround good result for Richie
soonack already to be more trusted than
kids Dharma uh on the economy but then
what about people's individual lives
well that's something where she's saying
that uh sort of basically Trails the
labor leader 44 for kirst armor but only
37 uh for Richie sineken I think that
probably reflects concerns that life is
probably going to get a bit worse for
people with less energy support next
year uh squeeze to the public sector and
uh keeping down that the public sector
pay and also fascinating this uh that
they trust kirst armor more than rissy
sunak 43-38 when it comes to dealing
with the energy crisis uh so some danger
there labor with a plan for a sort of a
nationalized Energy company uh the
conservative saying they're going to
massively reduce the amount of support
that they're going to give to the
country from next April from next year I
expect a fraction of the amount of
spending on keeping bills lower from
next year so that energy bill is going
to raise up the political agenda and on
that issue Kirsten are slightly best
better placed at the moment and be
fascinating to see how the public uh
judges that element of what they've got
to all do what we've all got to deal
with next year but a very clear message
from this government but the question is
does the public care more about managing
the big picture economy or about the
cost of living and themselves and that's
the difficult question for Richard Cena
and Jeremy Hunt it certainly it'll be
interesting to see if any of those poll
numbers change after next week as well
Sam we'll have more from you after this
short break
[Music]
the photographs that we start with in
the exhibition are the only set of
photographs the only photographic record
of arrival and selection of deportees to
a Nazi death camp
I was pleased that the exhibition is
there and people can see only also only
from the photographs what happened in
that camp maybe you know they they
appreciated more because there's lots of
people who never heard of Auschwitz
before so it's a good thing that they
put up this exhibition from the military
it brings back such terrible memories
it's heartbreaking when when I arrived
there to Auschwitz I came with my father
and with my father and my mother
and
the the screaming and bellowing get off
the train be quick my father jumped off
and I jumped after him by the time I
jumped off I didn't see him anymore he
had disappeared like Into Thin Air and I
never saw him again he was only 42 years
old
a young man I never saw him again
I was in Auschwitz
several weeks and
what we saw there it's impossible to
describe the main photographs that have
dominated our Collective memory come
from one single Source a photograph
album that was found just by chance
after the war uh immediately in the last
months of the war and contains almost
200 photographs but they are taken as
you say by the SS and so to a large
extent we've been forced to share the
Nazi gaze when we look at these
photographs we're not seeing photographs
taken with Compassion or with empathy
but rather dehumanizing photos and the
the key effort in this exhibition is to
try to re-humanize those in the photos
so we present the same images that
people may have seen before being rather
new ways some of them are life-size for
example so you have a kind of new
experience of witnessing where you're
standing alongside the arrivals at
Auschwitz you're looking directly into
their eyes and you're noticing details
that the photographer never intended to
capture
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
hello welcome back to safety Ridge on
Sunday the take where we take you back
through the mornings interviews with
some analysis from our Deputy political
editor at Sam Coates as well now we of
course spoke to the chancellor at head
of his big Autumn statement this week
but we also spoke to the leveling up
secretary Simon Clark who of course was
such a former I should say that such a
key part of the Liz truss Administration
and it was his first interview since he
was sacked by Rishi sunak now he I felt
wanted to give an intervention to say
what he would like to see next week and
it was pretty clear that he believes the
burden of spending should fall more
heavily on public spending cuts and tax
Rises so I asked him where he thought
those pending Cuts could be made
I think something like hs2 obviously
we've seen rail passenger numbers have
not recovered to pre-pandemic levels
particularly for commuter travel there
are real questions about schemes like
this which I think ought to be addressed
first before we cut things like defense
before we cut things obviously which
really matter to the public
so it does feel doesn't it as if there
is a bit of a fight Brewing among
conservative circles about those tax
Rises to come I also asked Simon Clark
to what extent this trust was to blame
for the current economic situation
making the point that for many of our
viewers they'll be saying why should we
listen to what you're saying
I would reject the idea that uh what's
happened in the economy is primarily uh
the result of what of the actions that
Liz took the the reality is that a third
of the global economy is now in
recession we are faced with
extraordinary headwinds uh coming out of
uh the situation in Ukraine which has
driven inflation to levels uh which we
haven't seen in my lifetime that
obviously comes on top of the legacy of
the pandemic not just the debt that we
incurred but also the uh the enormously
challenging societal and economic
consequences that we're still feeling
well let's bring our duty political
character to Sam Coates uh back what did
you make of Simon Clark
I mean he
incredible really in in many ways and
and why I'm just so struck by is just by
the scale of the difference of different
opinions within the conservative party
about how to manage the economy because
he's basically warning Jeremy Hunt not
to do lots and lots of the things that
we expect Jeremy Hunt to do the things
that he was on your program that Johnson
was on your program barely 20 minutes
before saying were very important for
them for the nation warning that really
you can't raise taxes Jeremy Hunter just
said everybody's going to pay more
particularly those with the broader
shoulders and then calling instead if
there is a black hole to be filled uh
then calling for that to come from from
cuts to you know to what he calls and
it's techy language you know investment
budgets Capital budgets but but in my
language much of that is leveling up you
know that that's the money that over the
next few years will go to pay for the
kind of infrastructure projects that
would regenerate many of the new areas
that the conservatives took for the
first time at the last election and and
and I think it's this massive Clash of
ideas we often talk about politics as a
class of personalities underlying that
Sophie he's an enormous disagreement on
the direction of the country and yes
there was quite a lot of justification
for why this isn't all Liz's fault he
was as you pointed out one of the top
four making key economic decisions
although he seem to slightly tiptoe away
from from from that just when you when
you pushed him
um but the people who backed the Liz
trust Vision are still in the
conservative party and whether it was
Simon clock or whether that was there it
was that little bit of Ian Duncan Smith
that you talked about that you showed
viewers earlier there is a group of
people within the conservative party
gearing up to oppose what Richard cynic
and Jeremy Hunter are going to announce
on Thursday now when Rishi Cena came in
as prime minister all those two and a
half weeks ago a lot of people said that
the grown-ups things are going to gonna
calm down but but if Simon Clark is
saying what Simon Clark said and Ian
Duncan Smith is saying what Ian Duncan
Smith said then it could quite quickly
get quite bumpy and that's going to be
difficult if people within the
conservative party are saying taxes are
rising too much spending is being cut
too much people's lives are going to be
made more miserable than they need to be
and if that's within the conservative
party they're finding those viewpoints
then then then then then how easy is it
to push very difficult decisions through
it's difficult isn't it as you say you
know we used your interview with in
Duncan Smith earlier in the week as well
as someone who was not you know a Rishi
sunak backer is it inevitable that after
you know the the bitterness that we've
seen of two almost back-to-back
leadership contests and all of the bad
blood that that causes that you're going
to end up having are these people who
are clearly making interventions before
the Autumn statement to try and swing
the chancellor one way or the other
of course it's not all happy families
inside the conservative party and people
who suggested otherwise on the arrival
of um talking nonsense the levels of
distrust dislike and in some cases
hatred within the conservative party
haven't just been ironed away there was
an incredibly nasty leadership contest
and and those fishes are still visible
whether it's about Economic Policy as
we've been talking about today or
whether it's that massive political
story that we were talking about at the
beginning of the week which was the the
departure of Gavin Williamson yes all of
that was about his completely
unacceptable messages
um there were genuine uh real
allegations of uh of bullying there and
he decided to stand down but there was
another layer to it Sophie which is
people within the conservative party who
aren't massive fans of Richie cnx
Administration trying to wind things up
to make his position worse to pick on
Gavin Williamson and get him out the
door and and that's the kind of low
level in fighting that's still going on
at the moment it shows that not
everything has particularly been solved
but it's not uh all smooth under under
the surface and I think and I think
people sometimes forget it and I do
wonder whether this statement on
Thursday that again just unpicks
everything a bit more or whether it's
the trial of Boris Johnson the televised
hearings into whether he lied that
starts to unpick the fabric of this
party uh or whether it's something else
but but but there were warriors under
the surface behind the scenes uh very
happy to to be disruptive because those
emotions and those differences those
policy differences are still so
incredibly live and it is just really
still quite fractious Sam I've got a
quick question for you I was actually
going to ask this to Jeremy Hunt but I
ran out of time so I'm going to ask you
it instead okay
um
we've been we're taking all this at face
value right spending carts tax Rises
are these all a fantasy are they all
going to come in in a few years time
after the election after things improved
is it actually real or do you think it's
just trying to calm the markets in the
short term
if this plan survived to the other side
of an election I'm a banana
there we go
we go thank you very much Sam coats uh
there you go that is it uh from sofa
Ridge on Sunday the take this morning
and the program as well really busy show
for us uh today the podcast is going to
be following around lunchtime we'll be
joined by the telegraph at Chris hope
we'll also be presenting a coverage of
course on Thursday of the all-important
Autumn statements and on Wednesday night
I hope you'll join us as well for the
take it is going to be another
absolutely bumper critical excruciating
week in British politics so
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]